there's two of them so one of them spoke
at the very first New York r
and at the very first Arc of
and he will always speak at the very
first conference in every city we put on
despite him being the reason I the only
time I've ever used stata was because of
him
I'm still bitter about that
and our other speakers are speaking with
him
met him at this conference
back when you gave a talk
she got a job of him and she gave a talk
the next year so she's also a repeat
speaker
and beyond that
our other speaker she actually teaches
Bollywood in in Maryland
so please welcome Max and Donya
I think for both of us which is kind of
crazy
um today we are going to talk to you
guys about how you too are an analyst
engineer
[Music]
so you're probably asking who are the
two of you maybe you're not because
Jared just gave a very nice introduction
but uh I'll tell you anyways so uh like
he said we both like R uh we met at this
conference uh and
um I only own one shirt which I am very
proud to be wearing today which I was
also wearing in 2015 when I talked about
survey analysis and then I wore it again
in 2018 when I talked about talking
about survey analysis and at that talk I
said I want an infinite recursion photo
so please get this photo where it's me
talking about me talking about me and
I'm just going to keep doing this every
single time
um enough about me Tanya so I don't need
that info minute recursion photo
um so I do change my outfit every time I
speak
but uh yeah in this picture over here
when Max was talking about SQL for
everyone that's actually when I met him
at this conference and I was in the
market for a new job and I met him and I
was like oh my gosh this sounds like a
great place to work and so rest is
history it's been four years
um in 2019 I had the opportunity to
speak here which was great in 2020 I did
it virtually and now I am super happy to
be back
um in person and yes my fun fact is I'm
also a Bollywood dance teacher at Zinda
Academy so if you ever want to do some
Bollywood dance I'm always down
um and then the actual important part
that's like related to us is that we're
also uh clean tech data scientist at
Arcadia hence the song energy yes
with that who are Arcadia who is Arcadia
I wanted to keep with the arbit so it
works
um this is from our website uh Arcadia
was a or is a uh uh a high growth tech
company that was founded here in DC
um and our mission is to clean up the
energy grid we're doing that two main
ways number one uh we are the leading
manager of community solar projects
which basically means solar projects
that didn't get installed on farms or
roofs and other people who don't live in
those houses who maybe can't access
solar from their roof are able to get
the value and savings of solar while
Greening the grid and the other product
line is our platform which is basically
taking the software we've built for
Community solar and Licensing that out
as a SAS tool for any data entrepreneur
any
um energy entrepreneur basically trying
to digitize the electricity Grid in many
ways that the financial sector has done
with like stripe and plaid making
working with energy data is simple API
with that uh do you want to talk about
Community yeah so Community solar is the
main line of business that Max and I
work on and I love Community solo for a
multitude of reasons
um one of one of the big ones is that it
truly is access to clean energy for
everyone so if you think about solar I
imagine that most of you guys think
about having solar panels on your roof
like this building like this building
for example
um and sometimes on the White House
depending on the president but
the issue with putting panels on your
roof is if you want don't own your roof
if your roof has trees near it if it's
not facing the right direction if your
credit score is not high enough there's
a multitude of reasons why solar is not
accessible to the general person however
with Community solar with building farms
near communities that allow you to get
that solar power from that specific Farm
you get access to uh to solar to all
people you pretty much democratize this
the access to renewable energy which is
also great for working against a lot of
the energy injustices that have come up
from using fossil fuels for many many
years and so what we do is primarily
focused on the data aspects related to
getting people access to the community
solar product by getting people onto our
platform so we can then service them
this is despite our talking about it not
the main thrust of our presentation but
we wanted to give that background if you
do want Community solar if you live in
Maryland DC or Virginia it is available
arcadia.com for more and that's the end
of the sales pitch yep what we're really
here to talk about is analytics
engineering raise your hand if you've
heard that word before
uh a couple hands all right so data
science is all about Venn diagrams right
we have the original Drew conwave
diagram where we're like you know uh
hacking and uh stats and domain
knowledge like danger like that's super
cool and exciting right so here is
another kind of starting to emerge Venn
diagram in the data Science World which
is it's great to follow Jake's
presentation about the importance of
data engineering and Donnie and I work
primarily in that big purple circle on
data analytics but what we're here to
talk about is how actually that
overlapping section analytics
engineering is really critical for the
success of any type of data work whether
it's analytics or machine learning or
what have you
yes
so with that um I'd like to tell a story
about how us two data scientists
discovered that we actually needed
analytics engineering for us to be able
to do our jobs so like I said before we
are an energy tech company we want to
get everyone who paid the power bill
onto a community solar program and
therefore we need to acquire customers
so we were like oh yeah we're data
scientists like we could totally do that
we can build predictive models we can
tell marketing that we can use our
predictive models to help Target certain
people in certain ways so we can help
them get onto the platform and we were
like ready to go and ready to build this
super cool predictive model in r
however
um any of you guys who have ever built a
uh uh a any sort of model
um you might notice that the hardest
part of it is actually cleaning your
data acquiring your data storing your
data cleaning your data making
definitions about what your data
actually means in a business context
um and then also once you do all the
modeling uh storing the results of your
model somewhere that's actually useful
being able to update it and iterate on
the model and then being able to export
the results of your model off to some
stakeholders so in our case this was
marketing people so we needed marketing
folks be able to access the output of
our predictive model
um in some sort of app or something and
we need to be able to enforce data
quality and document everything we did
so basically we were super excited we're
like yeah we can build this and then we
were pretty much
that's a halt and went wait we actually
don't have the infrastructure to do any
of this
and so what we really discovered is we
needed to build the foundations of a
data ecosystem we really needed
generation storage orchestration and
transformation of our data and then
using that we could then create export
and maintain governance and discovery of
our data
raise your hand if you think you do
ETL meaning extract transforming loading
of data
I mean come on no you if you open R
you're loading data in right you're
doing something and then you send that
data to somebody right that's the
classic I mean maybe you're not writing
the code to extract it from some hard to
reach place but you're doing some form
of detail
how many of you do elt extract load and
then transform
oh not as many hands okay well that is
kind of the real Innovation here how
many of you would say that you probably
spend ninety percent of your time
cleaning data munging data I'm seeing
more hands all right it's time we
embrace our true identities friends we
are data mongers we are data cleaners
this is nothing to be ashamed of this is
something to embrace this is something
to celebrate this is something to be
intentional about and so that's what our
talk is really about today is that
thinking about what we're doing with the
data cleaning process helps everyone
Downstream so your data might be
generated in Salesforce or it might be
generated in jira we saw great examples
from Jake the different places the data
can come from but then you need to be
able to
pull it together and so what we do is we
throw that into a data warehouse quickly
before we add a lot of information to it
and that allows us to then be
intentional about what we want to do
with it so let me tell you a story of
how we've evolved at Arcadia when I
started there which was only about a
year before Donya we just had one
primary application that we would pull
data from we would put it in one data
store at that time it was Amazon
redshift and then we would all hit
queries on it to just like answer
questions and that worked when we were a
team of one or two or three but we just
needed to scale so we then moved to a
concept of more of a data Lake where
we're pulling from all these other
systems especially as the company scales
we sign up for this SAS tool and that
SAS tool we have stripe data we have
zendesk whatever all the different data
systems that are producing data that you
want to be able to answer questions
across so now we're integrating all that
data into Data Lake but still you can
see from all the messy like lines that
are crossing now I have to query
something that's pulling from this SAS
tool and this corporate database and all
all these things and it's still messy so
what did we figure out that we needed we
needed a new concept which I don't love
the name of it but I guess when you have
a data Lake you need to organize a data
Lake and the term in Vogue has become
lake house which sounds pretty
pretentious and I guess it is kind of
pretentious but anyways that's the term
that I'm going to use to talk about how
we develop business Concepts on top of
that data lake so now you're not having
to hit all of the different assets but
you create common definitions from those
assets that can be used Downstream
so bringing this back to our concept we
want to be getting good data and then we
want to use it well and in doing so we
have different roles to play so we have
a data engineering team that helps us
Wrangle those data sets pull them into
our snowflake data warehouse that
extract and load step and then we have
our transform tool which we're using DBT
which I think stands for data build tool
it's basically a command line tool for
documenting and automating tests I'll
get more into what that is and that is
what we're really using for our data and
analytics engineering layer and then we
have our Downstream analytics and
modeling that flows from that and so
what we've realized is we have a role to
play as analysts not just in the
analytics Downstream but also in
defining the Core Business Concepts
so what are some of the advantages of
using a lake house or some sort of
um sort of transform layer
um first of all when we are developing
new business Concepts like Danny had the
example of what is a customer like how
do you define what a customer is
surprisingly hard you would think it's
easy it's actually very nuanced and lots
of people have different takes on it so
if you want to develop a concept of a
customer but then oh you got a new
product that just emerged and we need to
also consider them customers when before
we didn't call them customers okay I'm
going to change that but what's that
going to affect Downstream and all of
the other models and data sets so the
Lake House Runs tests and allows you to
see oh okay if you change the name of
this thing or you change the way it's
ingesting data it's going to break these
other things down that are being used so
it actually is bringing a kind of
engineering rigor to the analytics and
documentation that you're doing the next
thing are these configurable tests so
yeah the code QA is based like we can
push our code and it will run and create
a QA instance of it before we ever push
it live into Tableau or any business
intelligence tool Downstream so that
people can actually check it and see the
numbers and how they're going to change
before they actually change so then we
have the configurable tests which allow
us to be able to see
um uh you know did it break things
Downstream did this model break or not
and then last but certainly not least is
what I'm calling docs out of the box uh
because we are putting so much an
emphasis on bringing data all the way
through we're giving things good column
names we're writing descriptions we're
putting the tests all in this layer of
mostly yaml files and I'll show you what
it looks like in a second that then
automatically produces a website that
has erds like you can see this diagram
that's showing the how the tables flow
to each other and also has documentation
for Discovery and people to be able to
answer their own questions and
understand what's in the data
so very briefly here this is what it
looks like and feels like using DBT you
have vs code your code editor you're
managing your models on the left hand
side you're coding them with templating
language that basically compiles to SQL
sorry I'm still talking about SQL and R
conference I just can't help myself
um and then here on the right in the
yaml file is where you're doing the
documentation and so when you when you
build your DBT models it then creates
the table and runs all the tests that
you specified on it
okay so max likes to not talk about r at
our conferences um I'm going to try and
bring it back in a little bit so going
back to the original problem statement
what we were asked to do was to build a
predictive model that would predict the
likelihood of a customer staying a
customer
um given that they convert based on a
bunch of features and what we really
wanted to do was make this a production
ml model where the the customer so in
our case let me not use the word
customer the stakeholder which are in
our case is marketing will have the
latest version of our model that is
learning every time we get new data
every time we get new customers and
helps them identify who they should be
focusing on and so the basic first step
is the machine learning workflow right
so we need a bunch of model inputs in
this case we were looking at demographic
psychographic and Geographic data and we
were combining that with survival data
of passing customers and basically
survival data meaning how long did they
stay are they still a customer did they
leave when did they leave
um from there we did actually use r
um we use survival analysis packages in
our the specific ones being RMS survival
and survive minor
um and doing that we were able to create
this pretty nifty uh probability of
survival model at a selected time period
so essentially at 30 days we could say
this customer or this this individual
based on their demographic psychographic
Geographic data
um is whatever percentage likely to
still be a customer at 30 days or 90
days or one year what have you
but what we really wanted to do was take
that entire model
um and throw it into this DBT structure
so you are in a situation where you can
continue to get more observations
continue to have your model learn from
those new observations continue to make
different predictions
um and save those different predictions
into a production model that you then
send off um to your stakeholders so what
DBT uh suggests and the way that we
implemented it was with these three
different models one thing that is
confusing is with DBT uh the language
used a lot in analytics engineering is a
table is called a model but in uh in
modeling a model is called a model so
those two things are confusing
um in this particular case I am talking
about tables so the observations model
or table if you structure it in a way
where there's exactly one record for
observation that you can make a
prediction on you now have one set of
all the observations that you want to
apply your actual your survival model
onto
from there once you do the actual
survival modeling and you build your
model
um you want it to Output into a
predictions model or table in this case
and that table you want it structured
where there is exactly one record per
prediction but there might be multiple
records per observation meaning in this
case if you're customer one uh customer
one the first the first uh prediction
on 10 1 you have a prediction of one
year uh for the same customer one the
second prediction on ten two is 1.5
years because it learned from more
information that's an example
um and then finally you want your
production model so your stakeholder
always wants to know what is the latest
um version of this model with the most
information that has learned the most
and that is when you join your
observation model that has all of the
Geo demo
whatever psychographic data for your
customer and then the latest prediction
and that latest prediction is what gets
pulled into all of your reports and
exports
um and the entire cycle is
interconnected so a better way to look
at this
um is in visual diagram form so you have
your observations model table it goes
into your actual survival analysis model
the output goes into your predictions
model table and you pull those two
things together to your production model
table uh and that gets put out as either
an export a data export a report
whatever way you want to service this to
your stakeholder
awesome so
we've been on a journey Donya and I at
Arcadia on this
um there was a data engineer who was
like hey everyone I heard about this
cool tool called DBT should we try it
and half of our analysts are on PCS and
are more point-and-click and half of our
analysts are on Max we're on Max as you
can tell and we're more conversant in
the command line so it was scary change
is scary
um and so what what ended up being
really helpful was finding a community
of practice first within our company but
also outside of it talking to people to
understand like how this stuff is done I
mean this R conference is a great
example of a community of practice and
why we keep coming back here even as our
talks are less and less or more
tenuously related to R because having
people to be able to talk to about this
stuff makes it less scary I also think
that it's a team sport like this is a
thing where we didn't know right away
what to do so we started setting up like
an off office hour session and working
through it and then last but not least
like expertise is really valuable so
having a data engineer who was able to
start playing with it and understanding
how to actually implement it in our
GitHub instance and like that so we
could actually start using it and then
we as the analysts started translating
the benefit and explaining that to other
analysts and other people of the company
of like why we should be doing this and
spending the time but it really wasn't
until we hired somebody who had done
this at multiple companies who really
was able to bring a lot of that together
and so you know with that I want to
acknowledge a lot of the content here
comes from Sam Swift Our VP of platform
who helped us really think about DBT
he's given similar talks like this at
DPT conferences and I also want to
acknowledge and appreciate our our
colleague Nino who did a lot of the
modeling work as well and is now a data
scientist at GoFundMe
um and so yeah with that
um thank you all thank you